oh you reached the prices family phone
if you'd like to leave a message for
Adam career Thomas or I am you can do so
after the beep
[Music]
he didn't have to say with ena going low
you she told me she was pregnant and
then she lost the baby she made it up
she's never pregnant
did you faked your pregnancy I need you
to tell me the truth Corrine Adam this
isn't what you think there's more to
this where's MA I don't know what can
you not know where she do you I know you
two can having issues for a while what
do you know something that I don't
where's a shoe get it I'm gonna call for
backup
we've reason to believe that your wife
was at the scene of a murder this
doesn't make any sense this stranger
turns up all mysterious and drop some
bombs on people's and gone is this some
kind of joke
please don't tell that this stops now
what is it with you and your mother
sticking your noses into our business
now you know she's a liar nobody wants
this to be happening how's that lovely
wife feels I think we're done here
sherry stop is some kind of a trick
just wanna find up you'll have a secret
even you
[Music]
[Music]